hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 30 hört zu und spricht nach
während dem kino fehlen es sich gern
popcorn
während dem fußballspiel trinke ich
gerne bier während dem fußballspiel
trinke ich gerne bier während dem
unterricht im lehrer zu während dem
unterricht hörig dem lehrer zu während
der nacht schlafe ich während der nacht
schlafe ich vor dem unterricht lerne ich
die vokabel vor dem unterricht lerne ich
die vokabeln vor der zugfahrt kaufe ich
ein bild vor der zugfahrt kaufe ich ein
bild vor dem essen
wasche ich mir die hände vor dem essen
wasche ich mir die hände vor dem
training soll man nicht zu viel essen
vor dem training soll man nicht zu viel
essen nach dem unterricht mache ich die
hausaufgaben nach dem unterricht mache
ich die hausaufgaben nach dem frühstück
putze ich die zähne
nach dem frühstück putzig die zähne nach
dem training dusche ich nach dem
training dusche ich nach der party hatte
ich einen kater nach der party hatte ich
einen kater gefällt dir diese hose
gefällt dir diese hose ja sie gefällt
mir ja sie gefällt mir
nein
alt wir nicht nein sie gefällt mir nicht
passt dir das t shirt passt ihr das t
shirt
ja es passt wir ja es passt mir nein es
was mir nicht
nein es passt mir nicht gehört dir der
schlüssel gehört dir der schlüssel
ja er gehört mir ja gehört mir
nein er gehört mir nicht
was schenkst du herbert zum geburtstag
ich schenke
ihm ein parfüm ich schenke ihm ein
parfüm
was schenkst du annett zum geburtstag
ich schenke ihr eine kette
was schenkst du karin und oliver zur
hochzeit
ich schenke
ihnen neues geschirr ich schenke ihnen
neues geschirr helft die uns morgen beim
umzug
helft ihr uns morgen beim umzug schmeckt
euch das essen schmeckt euch das essen
der hut steht dir sehr gut
der hut steht dir sehr gut ist dass das
neue auto von francesca und julian ist
dass das neue auto von francesca und
juliana s gehört ihnen ja es gehört
ihnen
der stuhl ist aus holz
der stuhl ist aus holz die stümpfe
die stücke sind aus nylon die pullover
ist aus baumwolle
der pullover ist aus baumwolle
der gürtel ist aus leder
das fenster ist aus glas
das heft ist aus papier
das helfe
das papier der sack ist aus plastik
der sack ist aus plastik
das messer ist aus metall
das messer ist aus metall die pfanne ist
aus stahl die pfanne ist aus stahl die
schachtel ist aus karton die schachtel
ist aus karton
der ring ist aus gold
das wie lewis aus karbon
das video ist aus karbon das besteck ist
aus silber
das besteck ist aus silber
das zelt ist
stoff das zelt ist aus stoff die bonbons
sind aus zucker die bonbons sind aus
zucker die kerze ist aus wachs die kerze
ist aus wachs nicht vergessen dieses
video zu liken zu kommentieren und zu
teilen hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal hat dir das
video gefallen abonniere unseren kanal